hey guys my name is Jess it is the 9th
of November and America is getting any
president but the gaming news is still
churning so let's get into that
yesterday I told you how Skyrim special
editions first update arrived and today
I get to tell you that it's causing
serious technical problems because
that's how these things work reports
have been flooding in from plays
experiencing crashes across all
platforms both with and without mods
installed most accounts claim the
crashes occur after a few minutes of
play and while some have found success
in making new saves and loading the
problem seems to be persistent Bethesda
has told inquiring players struggling
with the bug that they are investigating
the problems next up by aware have said
that while Mass Effect Andromeda won't
be the start of a new trilogy that
doesn't mean it isn't more to come
creative director Mark Walters said on
Twitter to be clear just because
Andromeda isn't the start of a trilogy
doesn't mean we haven't been planning
for future adventures just not three
acts he added that Andromeda will not be
the last Mass Effect game by a long shot
Walter's explained at the end of this we
wanted to feel like a story has
completed yes for the universe there's
much more you could explore and we want
to tease that but it feels like its own
story it's like great I had my rider
sibling becoming a hero story what's
next is it going to be rider is it going
to be something else who knows finally
dishonor to has quite a sizable day one
patch gamespot can confirm the both the
ps4 and xbox one versions of the game
will prompt you to install a nut
gigabyte patch upon booting the game it
is possible to play without installing
the patch but doing so will sign you out
from PSN or xbox live but there's to
recommend you do install the update the
file size was originally reported by
reddit user legal trr who claimed that
the update improves loading times
texture streaming audio mixing frame
rate and shadow quality as well as
making a number of bug fixes just on the
two is out on November 11 usually this
is the part where I take some time to
tell you about the other news stories
you can find on gamespot but I want to
tell you about a 72 hour extra life live
stream it's starting on Friday at noon
and we'll be raising money to help
children in need
so be sure to stop by and I will see you
again tomorrow